hi I'm Jane Johnson I'm the mic project
manager at the library of congress I am
a librarian by training I was a working
cat
over for about 20 years at the UCLA film
and television archive as was Andrea a
library of congress prints and
photographs division and also the LA
County Museum of Art I'm just curious
how many of you have been to the Mike
site it's pretty good those of you that
haven't it's mike dot loc.gov that's
your destination when you get home let
me just start out here talking about
Mike as a tool for discovery most people
I think perceive Mike generally this is
primarily what we do we allow people to
discover moving images that's our Union
catalog which is essentially just a
database telling who's got what and
where and this is something that this is
kind of an additional layer of
functionality that we have that other
present hasn't been mentioned too much
in other presentations that we want to
link the images to the repositories that
hold them because we do have this
additional layer of functionality our
core functionality actually of
preservation then we have an archive
directory which it leads you to discover
organizations holding moving images and
then information about moving images and
their preservation and those are
information resources the Mike mission
is to immerse moving images in the
education mainstream recognizing that
what society uses it values and what it
values it preserves so you see we have
an education mission and a preservation
mission and what we're providing is the
tools to advance those missions we also
provide a platform for collaboration and
a research and development test bed
we're a collaboration between the
association of moving image archivists
and the Library of Congress this project
grew out of the US National Moving Image
preservation plans which I'll just
mention briefly a moment and our initial
development was funded by the National
science foundation we're part of the
National Science digital library this is
the mic homepage you can see here the
collections Explorer is where you search
the union catalog and if you go to the
advanced search that was just the quick
and dirty search of course here you can
limit by field within the record
metadata and you can also limit your
search by organization so this gives you
a lot more precision in your searches
the other thing that's interesting is
that you can search by organization and
sometimes you'll get a little better
functionality than that way than if you
actually walked into the door of one of
these archives taking the Library of
Congress i'll use my own institution as
an example it's actually a little bit
difficult or clunky to go into the
library of congress catalog and pull up
only moving images whereas with mike you
can go straight in here you can limit
your search and pull up only moving
images within our collection and this is
archived explore this is the archive
directory and the advanced search so
Mike release started out with these
movie image preservation plans which
were authorized by national legislation
in the US the redefining film
preservation came out in 1994 and then
the television and video preservation
followed three years later these are
really state of the field reports that
describe the crisis in film preservation
and they included a number of
recommendations and what the wider had
Congress did is it came to the
association of moving image archivists
and asked us to and I'm wearing two hats
here I'm also named my board of
directors so and andrea was a former
president anyway we have my CV you're
good tool again yeah we have a number of
amya members here I'm happy to see but
LC came to a Mayan asked us to put
together an implementation plan
and so what what we did is we went out
well we had like a number of task forces
were formed and we did the cataloging
task forces was gave us the seeds of my
we hired someone to do a feasibility
study that was grace Agnew and she not
only did a feasibility study she
actually built the plan and built the
ark developed the architecture for Mike
there are a number of components those
first the union catalog as I mentioned
the archive directory informational
resources all this is available through
a portal structure a really cool tool
that we have is a mapping utility or
mapping wizard that allows you to
actually take a local metadata schema if
you'd have your records in a database in
FileMaker Pro or access or even an Excel
spreadsheet you can then map those
through this mapping wizard and bring
you bring your records into the Mike
Union catalog the cataloging utility is
being developed right now at Rutgers
University Libraries based on their
workflow management system and that will
allow people to input people and
organizations to input their records
directly into the Mike Union catalog
I'll talk about that a little later and
then the service providers directory
which is being developed right now at
Georgia Tech and this is a parallel
development to the archive directory but
it lists organizations and individuals
who provide products and services for
moving image collections and this just
shows you our portal structure I don't
know if you can read that print but
we've got a general users portal and
archivist portal and a science educators
portal
now this is something that's unique to
Micah again this is the look the link
between the bibliographic records the
union catalog records and the archive
directory so it's not that we have a
union catalog database sitting over here
in an archive directory database sitting
over here they're actually integrated
this is something that was very
important to the archivist because they
thought of course a lot of physical
materials analog legacy materials that
really can't be viewed in their present
form so they didn't want to put their
records out there twenty-four/seven for
all the world to see then have people
calling their archiving and being
disappointed that they couldn't view
them waste the archives time and
disappoints the users so we developed
this integration of the two databases so
that when you pull up a record for
example here from the Peabody Awards
collection at the University of Georgia
you can link directly into their archive
directory record and find out what some
of their access policies are this would
be the archivist portal and this just
shows you that on the left side left
hand navigation bar tends to be links to
existing resources on the internet and
then the it's not a good this page is in
a really good example but usually in the
portal home pages you'll see why
original white papers written by experts
in the field usually am ia members and
this is part of my mission and this is a
mice placed in the partnership the
Library of Congress provides staffing
management infrastructure and am ia
primarily develops the resources the
informational resources that you find on
the site and you'll see within archivist
portal there are three sub portals
catalog and metadata preservation and
programming through exhibition and this
is just an example
the Lynx footage calculators film stock
date codes course spring the archivist
portal and this is technical information
resources the cataloging utility is a
front-end input form for the Union
catalog records now the Union catalog as
it exists right now is primarily
descriptive metadata for those of you
that distinguish between all the
different types of metadata descriptive
are those types of metadata that apply
to any man any manifestation of a work
so be the title the summary the credits
that type of thing but what the catalog
utility will give us as well is
administrative metadata technical
description as well as descriptive and
rights metadata as well eventually so
the catalog utility gives you can have
all this functionality with a low
overhead and infrastructure requirements
it is a mets implementation which is a
library of congress standard and
international standard for metadata and
it's based on the workflow management
system at rutgers who is mike well the
development team initially was rutgers
university libraries University of
Washington and Georgia Tech Rutgers
developed the union catalog in the back
end of that they knew Washington
developed the archive directory and
Georgia Tech worked on the website and
the search engine we had an evaluation
team that conducted user studies for
that we partnered with the library
school a trucker's have a science
educated how to science educators
advisory board to help develop the
science educators portal and then the
community participants and those would
be mostly am ia members so our alpha
sites were seen in the library of
congress National Geographic television
you can see them out here and these were
chosen not just for a range of the
collections that they held but also for
different types of metadata
that we could hit any different kinds of
idiosyncrasies and quarks with the
metadata and make sure that everything
worked in the system across the broad
range of metadata schemas that are out
there additional sites and the
humanities were fortunate off video
archive at Yale Pacific Film Archive at
UC Berkeley and the pranker collection
at the Internet Archive I want to talk
just a little bit about our metadata
strategies we haven't talked about
metadata too much today but I have to
get that in there but before I do so I
just want to mention this is the most
salient characteristic in the archival
moving image field is the diversity
because we have diversity everywhere you
look in this field collections in terms
of genres form subjects physical formats
digital file formats institutional types
as we know moving images are now found
in any type of an institution that's out
there every kind of size with all
different kinds of missions the
financial resources available are vastly
different from organization to
organization there are different
constituencies so different user needs
so therefore different metadata
standards are employed so what we try to
avoid is imposing a single standard from
above our metadata strategies first is
just to promote metadata standards and
this is a bit of a balancing on a beach
ball act because we've got we want to
embrace that diversity but we also want
to promote standards we also want to
extend standard metadata use to
everybody so that people get into the
habit of using standards there are a lot
of reasons to use standards which I'm
sure you're all quite aware of we also
want to enable exploration of new
technologies and provide an extensible
model in fact the name Mike was chosen
moving image collections in part because
it could be changed later on to media
inc elections which was an
acknowledgement that we hope to bring in
sound recordings and other types of
materials at some point
so how do we promote standards first
just by illustrating by example the
value of standards and you can see this
when the organization's contribute
records to the Mike Union catalog
particularly small organizations with
idiosyncrasy do syncretic local systems
that they've been homegrown systems that
they've been developed in-house often
without a lot of expertise and when they
see their records in the context of this
larger catalog it's very clear you can
see the light bulb go on in people's
heads as to how the practices might
differ and if ur might change and they
do actually go in in some cases and
change their records at least
prospectively if not retrospectively and
also we educate archivists in the use of
standards that's the information
resources I'm just going to cruise
through some of these a little faster
embracing the diversity not only
encourages participation but of course
it also opens new avenues for record
distribution I don't want to bore you
too much with this slide but we do have
a core registry which allows us to map
records from all these different
metadata schemas and export them and
different metadata schema switch and
each one of those has a different
purpose and allows you to distribute the
records in a in a different way for a
really broad distribution and then
extending standard metadata used to all
that's primarily through the cataloging
utility then which will allow people
with very low infrastructure and X and
not so much expertise to go ahead and
make standard records enabling
this is talking about Matz's the LC
encoding standard we also map to MPEG 7
which is unusual this is developed this
is one of the few schemas out there was
developed specifically for moving images
it supports multiple manifestations
which a lot of other things don't so if
you have files in different formats and
different physical formats it does
support that description of all those
things and linking between all those
different manifestations it accommodates
all the whole range of metadata and also
what has been mentioned several times
here today it supports automatic
generation of segments as well as
non-textual low-level indexing so facial
recognition that kind of thing we've got
so much volume material coming out this
is going to become more and more
important as we know this is just a
screen snapshot of an old actually an
older version of the catalogue utility
that shows how you go about inputting
records so you can look at the different
types of you put in the descriptive
metadata than the rights metadata the
technical metadata you can create
templates so that you can enter many
objects that have common metadata and
just change a few elements and the
mapping wizard you just submit an
application you send sample records and
a list of data elements and basically
the system populates a template which
allows you to go through field by field
and just and look at how we define each
field for example title will say this is
how we define title here's a list of
your data elements which you gave us
choose from the pulldown menu which of
your data elements is the same as what
we call title and then they just go
through element by element and really
for most databases that can be done in
about 20 minutes so it's very fast and
the records can be distributed very
this helps small organizations make
their holdings accessible on the web at
low cost and accordance with standards
and with existing personnel and
infrastructure and larger institutions
like the Library of Congress we have so
many legacy schemas we can actually
bring them into performance by exporting
bring them into the mic union catalog
mapping them through through our schema
and then exporting them in a single
scheme some of our partnerships of
course the Library of Congress and am ia
which is a unique partnership which
really utilizes or exploits the
strengths of both organizations so it
come up with the whole that's greater
than the sum of the parts the three
University developers we've also used
the mic architecture and other projects
at Rutgers and in New Jersey in the New
Jersey digital highway uses a lot of the
development work that was done for Mike